i think i think i just i just realized
like right now
i just think i don't like peanuts okay
americans is it normal to feel
re like violently uncomfortable after
eating more than two of those cups is
that normal
melon is that normal do you feel does
your stomach feel really into how many
how many rhesus cups can you eat you can
eat like a bunch
two yeah you start to feel like real
uncomfortable right
why i mean there was no pat there was
they came in a nice pack of three so i
assumed
i eat all three oh you don't [ __ ] that
is
that is the biggest lie amount that i
was ever told you share you share share
bags my ass why would they why would
that
mean my hand fits so perfectly anymore
that's like saying oh you can break off
a kick cat and share it with another
person no one [ __ ] does that [ __ ]
just open it's eating i don't want
someone with their [ __ ] sweaty hands
snapping a kitkat that whole palm
reaching over the whole kitkat to snap
it
that's what you have to do i don't trust
the person who tries to do it like that
that's weird
you want to clean it yeah you want that
i also don't want your whole palm
touching though that's a lot a little
too much palm so i don't i i
frankly we'll just buy our own kitkats
you know just just eat the [ __ ] or
honestly in the packet rip it in the
packet because you can do that if you oh
yeah you can if you have
big that's too big but sometimes you
forget you've opened it up you're like
[ __ ]
i can't i can't wrap it back up grab the
packaging just
you got to do like have you ever seen in
the kitkat adverts where you got like
the foil wrapping and then you just like
split it
in the middle with like a knife no no
with your finger you're like
it's just splits perfectly what was i is
does this is your finger now long enough
no it it is have you been like okay
did that advert stop getting played or
something i've never
seen that oh my god
how do you eat kitkats just [ __ ] take
it out of the package to eat it
okay i haven't done that but i don't
believe you that you've never split
oh because like because the kitkats i
always used to get were like the
kind of mini packets of cute cats so
it's like it would be in a bag
you've never had a single kitkat you've
only had like a full
bar kit yeah yeah and i didn't eat it no
you [ __ ] off
joey
do you just [ __ ] bite that [ __ ]
without splitting it yeah no
no no no joey no no
i am true no i don't believe that you've
never
cracked the kitkat i don't i don't do it
on a on the [ __ ] rags though
if i mean kitkat who the [ __ ] even
kick cat often no but like every time i
have a kitkat it's usually like
it's usually in like the you know like
two kitkats together right yeah yeah
yeah yeah max is like four in a row yeah
and right right
split it i don't know literally just
grabbing just
don't do this no joey no
because like the crumbs get everywhere
and [ __ ] no i just need in one go
like it's such a mess like crumbs go
everywhere the wafer falls
the structural integrity has been
compromised frankly it doesn't matter
because two seconds later it's all going
in your mouth
pretty sure like society would crumble
if everyone did that joey jesus christ
[Laughter]
you about this in your life there's no
way you went through school eating
kitkats like that no goldberg i never
ate kitkats in school
cats kitkats were a me thing in my room
what's wrong with you it's a [ __ ]
chocolate bar
who cares does it say
on the packaging must crack one at a
time
in order to eat successfully no it
doesn't it's it's like it's like
only drinking beer via like shotgun
yeah okay as a one-off i get it but like
that shouldn't be your primary go-to
method of drinking a beer again you know
like
like stabbing a hole in the bottom and
[ __ ] drinking that shouldn't be your
like go-to method you know what i mean
it's like that it's like that's
something like that it's like that
it is you're literally making it like
harder to eat
i'm not i'm making it easy because i'm
saving the my [ __ ] palms from getting
all chocolatey by doing this
oh my god oh my god i just like open it
up halfway
and then grab it by the packaging and
then just [ __ ] there's a reason there
are crevices in the kitkat joey
there are reasons for it it's it's it's
literally designed into the [ __ ] food
product it's designed to be eaten a
certain way joey look sometimes
i want to break the rules all right [ __ ]
society